Think you know hyperspace in the Star Wars
universe?
Think again — because Ahsoka is changing
everything we know about the concept of lightspeed
travel.
Following an action-packed and fan service-filled
fifth installment, Ahsoka has returned to
Disney+ once more.
This episode, appropriately titled "Part Six:
Far, Far Away," places the focus on Sabine
Wren, who has traveled to a new galaxy alongside
the villainous Morgan Elsbeth, Baylan Skoll,
and Shin Hati.
While the villains meet with Grand Admiral
Thrawn, Sabine embarks on a search for her
long-lost friend, Ezra Bridger, on an unfamiliar
world.
At the same time, Ahsoka Tano and Huyang travel
inside the mouth of a purrgil, venturing through
hyperspace to rescue Sabine and stop Thrawn's
sinister plan.
We only see a brief scene of the two heroes
early in the episode, though it does raise
one big question.
As the purrgils embark on their voyage to
a new galaxy, hyperspace takes on a very different
appearance to what Star Wars fans might know.
Rather than its usual swirling white and blue
look, the simu-tunnel the purrgil pod moves
through is streaky and multicolored, featuring
green, orange, and indigo hues.
While this is most likely how the minds behind
Ahsoka wanted to convey to viewers that the
purrgil are traveling to a different galaxy,
there could be more to this new hyperspace
look.
"Punch it!"
Purrgil are among the most fascinating creatures
in the Star Wars universe, and not just because
of their look or backstory.
Rather, it's their unique biology that makes
them so interesting.
These massive space-faring whales breathe
in a gas called Clouzon-36, which their bodies
take in and turn into hypermatter fuel.
When sufficiently fueled up, their tentacles
will glow, and they'll make the jump to hyperspace,
venturing from galaxy to galaxy at their leisure
— until they need to take in more gas once
again.
Everyone else in the Star Wars galaxy can
only jump through hyperspace using a ship
with an operational hyperdrive.
In this case, their Clouzon-36-based fuel
is refined by other means — and certainly
not inside the body of a purrgil.
Thus, you could argue that the purrgil simu-tunnel
on Ahsoka looks different than the one previously
seen in Star Wars because it is unique to
the way in which the purrgil travel.
Perhaps the way they synthesize Clouzon-36
inside their bodies results in hyperspace
looking different than it would if you used
synthetic hyperfuel?
Of course, for fans who are familiar with
Star Wars Rebels, it won't be anything new
to experience a more colorful form of hyperspace
travel.
Even without the presence of purrgils, the
series depicts multicolored tunnels on multiple
occasions.
For example, in the Season 1 episode "Gathering
Forces," the Ghost accidentally jumps into
hyperspace courtesy of a Rodian agent named
Tseebo.
After an Imperial tracker is placed on the
ship's auxiliary vessel, the Phantom, Ezra
Bridger and Kanan Jarrus concoct a plan to
detach it during a hyperspace jump.
The risky move pays off, but not without a
bumpy and very vibrant fall first.
In the following season, Rebels fans witnessed
a similar sight during the events of "Stealth
Strike."
Traveling through hyperspace in a blockade
runner, Ezra and Commander Sato are confronted
by a dangerous Imperial weapon: an Interdictor-class
Star Destroyer.
The experimental ship is capable of pulling
other ships out of hyperspace, something it
does with ease to the heroes' own vessel.
As they lose control of their ship, the blues
and whites of hyperspace are replaced by streaks
of red, yellow, and violet.
Of course, eagle-eyed fans might have noticed
that the villains' hyperspace journey in Episode
6 was nearly as colorful as that taken by
the purrgil.
This could mean that a vibrant simu-tunnel
is merely a quirk of this new galaxy — or
that the Eye of Sion somehow utilizes the
purrgil's abilities to travel into the unknown.
All of this hyperspace confusion just goes
to show that Star Wars space travel is far
from an exact science.
Maybe someday, a project will come along that
better explains the ins and outs of hyperspace
— but for now, all we can do is speculate
on the truth behind its many colors.